c'est du kung fu vous préparez pas les
jeux olympiques on vous préparer pour la
rue action je vous demande d'accueillir
le net oui doublé
wang jackman il a quitté le temple
shaolin pour voir ce que dans le kung fu
en amérique à chinatown ou on aime pas
de gens saignent à blanc les shaolin
envoie où jackman pour missionné je
crois que c'est la seule personne au
monde qui pourrait détruire tout ce que
j'ai eu tant de mal à mettre en place
tôt ou tard je devrais l'affronter
qu'apprend-t-on au cours de maître lee
on apprend à botter des culs et à botter
des culs
votre technique est impressionnante mais
elle connaît une limite laquelle je suis
l'avenir ou le passé mais pas crédible
wang
affrontez moi j'accepte votre défi
m
pas de règle tous les coups sont permis
est impossible vous allez vous entretuer
[Musique]
maintenant vous commencez à dépasser vos
limites quelles limites
non